- TikTok, as you guys
know, I'm no Zach King,
I don't do magic tricks, but...
(cards shuffling)
52-card pickup, oh, I got it!
You're gonna fuckin' die.
(ominous music)
- [Caleb] Boom.
Wow!
That's actually better than you--
- And this is "WeeklyVee"
001, motherfucker!
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ Immortal, immortal, immortal ♪
(steady hip-hop music)
(digital beeping)
- Yo, what's up, "WeeklyVee"?
New world.
I'm here with Tyler and Andy talking about
how we're gonna do it.
So we're gonna go kinda sequential, right,
like, Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
Some days I'm not gonna film
at all, or be off the grid,
but I gotta make little
videos like this on what's up.
So, what's up is we're
fuckin' back, right?
First day back in the office in 2020,
rollin' in real quick,
doin' some finance meetings,
doing some Team Gary meetings,
little WineText conversation,
little community text talk.
And I'm headed to the airport now,
we're headed to Vegas to CES.
I'm gonna be a little
late for a major event,
mainly 'cause Tyler fucked up
real, real, real, real, real good,
thought I had something important
at nine a.m. this morning that
ended up not being confirmed.
Otherwise, I would've been on
a six, seven, or eight a.m. flight
and been completely proper at CES.
But Tyler starts off the new decade
with one of the top
five mistakes he's made
in the last five, I mean, Ty--
- It's true!
- [Gary] One could argue this is as big
of a mistake as you've made.
- It's potentially true.
- [Gary] Top three, for sure.
- I think in my first three
months of working with Gary,
there were some logistics fuck-ups, where
he was speaking, maybe, in like
Topeka, Kansas, or something like that,
and we booked him for
something the next morning
that he was contractually obligated to,
and he would have taken
a commercial flight,
but we had time zones wrong,
so he had to take a $30,000 private flight
simply because I fucked something up.
Next, I would say there was
definitely a 10 Hudson Street
versus 10 Hudson Yards mess-up
that probably cost us some
new business in the past.
Yeah, that was a good one.
I actually posted about that
on Instagram the other day.
Three is email.
I've definitely missed some
emails from some people
that you don't want to miss an email from,
and then you lay in bed
at night and realize,
"How did you miss it?" 'cause
you actually looked at it,
realized it was important.
Sometimes the most important things
are staring you in the face,
and you do less-important things instead
because it's easier.
And that's a hard thing for
all people to accomplish.
- Anyway, that's where
we're at, "WeeklyVee."
(lively music)
♪ First they tell you that they love you ♪
♪ Then they ask where you coming from ♪
♪ Like you the only one
feeling how you feeling ♪
♪ Then you lie just to
make it sound appealing ♪
- So this is "WeeklyVee" now.
Quick little video from yesterday you saw,
which, now we're here.
It's Tuesday morning, we're in...
- Uh.
- Vegas.
DRock, I hope you caught me
picking my teeth with a piece of paper.
I do think that's one of my funny hacks,
and probably completely inappropriate,
but that's what "WeeklyVee"'s about.
I'm here with Harriet, Harriet.
Smile.
- Hi.
- Harriet runs comms at Vayner.
We're talking about, you know,
Vayner's really having a coming-out party.
Last year was probably the
year we got the most press.
Some of you saw, and
maybe we can pop it up
right here in the vlog
now, the Campaign magazine,
which is one of the most
prestigious industry magazines,
had a really fun cover story on me,
"Wrong, Wrong, Wrong,"
about a post on Instagram,
which I rarely do, and so.
A lot of you know me as the speaker,
or the Instagram thing, entrepreneur,
social media guy, but I
think one of the things
we'll probably do with "WeeklyVee,"
now that we have a new format,
and today's exactly four years from?
- [DRock] Three days.
- Three days later, but
four years from when,
what, "DailyVee" one?
- No, it'd be three.
- Three, the Vegas one.
"DailyVee," 003.
DRock!
- Yep?
- Get in here!
I mean, we've gotta show
people that I shower.
They may think I smell, DRock!
So, basically, I'm gonna do a lot more
inside look to me, the executive.
You know, I'm running a 1000-person
global holding media agency,
publishing, speakers conglomerate,
along with VaynerSports,
which you'll probably see a lot of
over the next eight to 12 episodes
of "WeeklyVee," because we have a massive
draft class and a lot going on there.
We've got Mobile, Alabama, Senior Bowl,
we've got the combine,
we've got the Super Bowl,
we've got the draft in April.
So, the next 12 episodes of "WeeklyVee"
will have a ton of VaynerSports.
Mike Nelligan, head of marketing,
a lot of you should be
doing stuff with him.
Maybe a pop-up video to the
LinkedIn thing we did there.
So I think, as we go into a new format,
I think it's gonna be
important for us to continue
to inform and educate and entertain,
and I think taking something
from zero to $200 million
in revenue from scratch
takes a lot of operations leadership,
and I think we're gonna challenge,
I'm almost making this right now for DRock
as much as for you guys,
and challenge ourselves
to show you some more angles.
2020!
(steady hip-hop music)
(static)
Incentive them to not, the
whole thing is ROI positive.
You missed one of my great
thesises there, DRock.
You missed the first 30 I ate.
- [DRock] I missed the first part of it.
- I know you did.
You want me to give it to you?
'Cause you want them to have it?
- Can't get 'em all!
- I think people overanalyze things,
and they want every single action
and every single printed
thing and every coupon
and every speech and every
movement to create a direct ROI.
I view it in the macro,
so we've printed out,
Vayner, this year, now
has consulting products,
and not just services, so we created this,
I came up with this idea of a
cheeky diner menu, laminated.
We have a bunch of them
here for our events.
I was just telling
Harriet, "Let's make sure
"at all our events that
all the potential clients
"that we're meeting with
actually leave with it."
And I was saying to her,
"It's so big and cumbersome,
"I would throw, like, I would be nice,
"if I was on the other side, I'd be like,
"'Oh, thank you, Harriet,
yeah, I love Vayner,'
"and I'd walk and throw
it in the garbage."
99 out of 100 people would do that.
The punchline is, though, everything here
is a $250,000 to $10
million thing to sell.
All you need is one person to actually,
I don't wanna ruin too many of these,
is to kinda go like this, go like this,
or go like this and take a photo,
all you need is one person to convert
to make the printing of all this
and the effort of all
this to be ROI positive.
Big business doesn't go tit-for-tat.
It's far more in the macro.
It's why I give so much.
The karma results in opportunity
far more than people
realize, and it feels good.
That's why I do it.
- [DRock] So, what do
you call that strategy?
Like, I'm trying to
think of a lower third.
- I call that strategy actually
building a fucking business.
That's what I call that strategy.
No, really, I think everyone's like,
"How am I gonna raise capital?"
"How am I gonna flip this business?"
When you're building something forever
and trying to build something humongous,
it's never transactional.
It's always macro.
It's why I take a lot of thought
in how we exit employees.
It's not about, "We need
to fire this person today
"to save the extra
$4,000 in their salary,"
it's, "We need to do it with grace
"so that there's a good vibe between us,
"even though it's a negative
situation, in five years."
- Yeah.
- I mean, this is great.
I mean, revenue for states
saves us in tax dollars.
- [DRock] Are you on it, or is it audio?
- It's happening anyway.
It's a good piece.
Mike, hold on one second,
can we find a video?
You know how I wanna do
that Deshaun Watson thing?
Could we find a current
video where they say
online gambling is exploding,
doing well for the states?
That's what it starts
with, you see what I mean?
And then, got it.
But this technology
movement is inevitable.
It's time for him and everybody else
that's getting hurt by it
jumping on the offense.
- All right, embrace the
future, don't run away from it.
Sue, next to you.
- Every conversation here at CES,
99.8% of it will lack any,
any common sense whatsoever.
(audience laughs)
People, the majority of the
human beings that come here,
will talk in theory and thesis
and B2B corporate justification talk,
not how to actually make something happen.
And so, if you actually care
about making something happen,
what will end up happening is,
we will finally have a debate
around creative at scale.
We will have the debate that creative
is actually subjective, the quality.
That we spend an
uncomfortable amount of time
on the production value,
when we justify it
versus its effectiveness
in what we're trying to achieve.
We are in a very, very interesting time,
because people overvalue things
that they don't fully understand.
We talk a lot about big data
in all those conversations
that are gonna happen
here, but the reality is,
almost everybody here this
week is a nonpractitioner.
If you actually set up a
Shopify or an Amazon store,
or a YouTube channel, and
you actually made content
on 50 different platforms
and actually ran media
on those 50 platforms, you'd
actually have something to say.
Because right now, the far
majority of opinions in this room
are predicated on headlines
they read somewhere
and or the financial vested interest
of what they're currently selling.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I'm starting a media company,
but I just want advice.
How do you manage a team of videographers
and video editors to kind of
be more creative in that sense,
and motivate them as well?
- I think, A, you need to make
sure, like I said up there,
that if you're the judge and the jury
of what is good or bad,
it's already vulnerable.
I think what you do is you
overcommunicate to them.
I gave DRock and the rest of the team
a ton of freedom, and then
I would overcommunicate,
like, "Oh, I love that," "Eh,"
but I never had the
audacity that I was right.
And the vulnerability
for you in this situation
is that you're right,
the consumer's right.
So you gotta let it go out.
- Got it.
- So I think you having humility
will open up the creators
to have more freedom.
Don't forget, you have the power.
When I think DRock sucks, I
can say, "DRock, you're fired."
(duck quacks)
- On my watch, but not on my phone.
- What?
- I'm fired, I got fired.
- Okay, so I work at Shell.
- Yes.
- It's considered a premium brand
because our price point's a bit higher
than your average street
price of gasoline.
How can we convert our consumers
that are maybe early, mid-career,
that don't have as much disposable income,
that there's actual value
in buying from Shell?
- Your business is wildly based
on convenience of location.
Like, you know--
- We have the largest
footprint in the U.S.
- I'm aware, which is
why you're doing well.
I think if you're actually talking about
trying to communicate
to people other value
than convenience, I think it goes back
to what I spoke about before.
Every value prop you
have, obviously, gasoline,
for example, if you've got a highway
and there's four corners of you
and three other competitive gas stations,
your ability to one-mile-radius ads
to communicate to that group
and those surrounding towns
that you are the best
actually creates a scenario where somebody
will go and U-turn even though
that's not their direction
to get gas from you.
The problem is, the marketing
that the organization does
is too up here, it's brand, it's vanilla,
and you need an ad for the people
that live within a two-mile radius
of the fuckin' four corners
of the gas stations.
Your ad on Facebook that makes a reference
to the pothole on the
other side of the highway
is what actually converts to business.
That comes through real insights
and real hand-to-hand
combat of creative making.
- Nice, I like it.
All right, sweet.
- [Fan] Can I just get a picture, brother?
- Yes, sir.
- The look.
It's very obvious, and you instantly know
this means that this needs
to be clipped for Instagram,
TikTok, Twitter, whatever.
It's usually when we're out in the field
and it's just like it almost sends
a lightning bolt through your body.
You just know this has to
get clipped immediately,
and make it up, right, DRock?
- Yeah.
- Right.
(melodic hip-hop music)
- Gang, I gotta go on a conference call.
I'll try to sneak in a couple more things,
but I'm already five minutes late.
Thank you, bro.
- Thank you, appreciate it.
- If anybody wants a quick photo,
and then I'm just gonna get on the call.
Thank you, guys.
- I just wanted to say you
made me go TikTok viral
the other day because I listened
to your content as well.
- That makes me happy.
- 100,000 views.
- Good for you, brother.
- And I'm trying to become...
Would you make a TikTok
real quick with me?
- Go for it real fast, 'cause
I'm about to go on this.
- All right, with GaryVee--
- Yo, TikTok!
Do it!
- GaryVee made me go viral!
- You made yourself go
viral, you just executed it.
- GaryVee Challenge!
(melodic hip-hop music)
- So many of you are
crying about not growing
and not replying to every single comment
you're getting in the comments section.
One of the great ways to grow depth,
which leads to word of mouth,
and people talking about you,
which then leads to followers,
is actually engaging in
your comments section.
Come on, it's 2020.
Try some new shit instead of crying
that Instagram's algorithm's fucked up.
Fuck your fuckin' excuses!
Fuck the algorithm!
I'm winnin' on this algorithm.
You can, too.
I will never, ever, ever...
Nest egg.
Make a bet that doesn't allow me
to have a roof over my head.
Facts.
I think there's a lot of ways...
Could be a shitty roof, though.
People are not betting on
their sweat equity enough.
People don't wanna work!
People, money is the shortcut,
so that's why people borrow it and get.
I don't know what year
that video's from, DRock,
but, same shit.
I'm consistent as fuck.
- Okay, so what happens
is, we find old videos
where Gary was right in, like, 2013.
So we then send that video to Gary,
he records context, and
then sends it back to us
and we edit the video like that.
♪ He likes my diamonds and my pearls ♪
♪ I say, "Thank you, I designed it" ♪
♪ Not your average girl ♪
♪ He needed swag and I provided ♪
♪ 'Vided ♪
♪ Open up and bite it ♪
♪ Bite it ♪
♪ Shut up, boy, and bite it ♪
♪ He don't know no better ♪
♪ Heard he got that cheddar ♪
- All right.
- In the same place?
- Just had a meeting
with one of my favorite executives, Pedro.
Good meeting, bad meeting?
- Awesome meeting!
You watch, it's similar
to a lot of my content,
but a little bit more thoughtful,
and I really, really, really need you
to all leave right now and
go watch my latest post.
It's about me being right
about online gambling
and state-by-state gambling.
You'll see it.
But I'm tellin' you, I'm tellin' you,
you've gotta go look at it.
You've gotta go look at
it, go understand it,
'cause it's a macro
unlock to a ton of shit.
All right, I'm going
into the VaynerX party,
filming my own shit.
And you know DRock is here, "WeeklyVee."
This is a networking event
where we have a ton of potential clients
and current clients.
Harriet, come on.
Just, we good?
Harriet makes another appearance.
Anyway, going inside, networking,
trying to make shit happen.
See ya!
♪ Money won't make me stay ♪
♪ I got my own paper ♪
♪ Move 'cause you're in my way ♪
♪ Why you gotta ruin my day, my day ♪
♪ Money won't make me stay ♪
- It's been a really busy day.
It started with a CMO, CMO, Fortune 500,
CMO, Fortune 500, 10:30,
CEO and CMO, Fortune 500 at
11, head of marketing at 11:30,
head of TikTok business,
head of a toy company,
media, head of an OTT marketing.
We're about to have a little wine tasting.
Show it, DRock.
Andre and Harriet are right now
getting their shit together.
We have ad hoc, at CES, people
are planned out like crazy,
and I think one way to win
is to break the system.
So even though everybody has their plans,
we're now into day three
here, as it's Wednesday,
for a lot of people,
and people are fatigued,
so we just blasted out
an email, text, WhatsApp,
DM to a bunch of senior
clients that we're just doing
a pop-up wine tasting with
Empathy here in a suite at Aria,
which is a central place for CES,
and we have, like, 20, 30
legit potential clients
and current clients coming
within a two-hour window,
so, a little hacking, which is fun.
The menus have been huge.
You know, the big learning for all of you
in "WeeklyVee" on that is,
VaynerMedia's taking an approach
where there's really only seven ways
to work with us now, instead
of meet with somebody
and try to figure it out,
which means there's a million ways,
and in that restriction,
creates enormous opportunity.
I think we're seeing a lot of opportunity
in the sales funnel this week as well,
'cause we're making it easier for clients
to say yes, no, or maybe so, or one,
two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So, a lot of stuff, but DRock, I think
if we're gonna do this "WeeklyVee" thing,
one of the things that you
and I have to work on is,
on days like this where we recapped,
where you missed all the B-roll
that I told you that we
could've done, DRock was to,
this is really fun.
We just had an interesting moment.
The reason we're making this video is,
DRock was talking about,
"It's gonna be weird with
'WeeklyVee' on a day like this,"
'cause we couldn't film,
'cause, as you heard,
it was all CEOs, CMOs.
I said, "DRock, you can't deploy
"'DailyVee' thought process
and producing prowess
"to 'WeeklyVee,' 'cause
it's a different show,"
and he was like, "You're right."
And so, he was like, "You
wanna do something now?"
I'm like, Yes, "But
what we could've done,"
because a lot of you don't know
how much I'm the CEO of this company,
as we could've had a camera
the whole time in that angle,
'cause the clients were sitting here,
and really shown seven hours
condensed into three minutes,
put a fuckin' hot DaBaby song over it,
and really show you, hey.
So many people are like,
"What does GaryVee do?
"He just travels and speaks,"
and shit of that nature,
like 98% of what I, no.
82% of what I do is be executive
of this massive marketing company
and holding company, VaynerX, which has
PureWow and One37pm and VaynerSpeakers
and Tracer and VaynerMedia
and The Sasha Group
and I got a lot going on in
Singapore, London, New York.
So I'm excited about
"WeeklyVee" 'cause I think
we've established certain
things with "DailyVee"
that I'm really excited, and
we really have a challenge,
because you approached
today like "DailyVee."
And it's gonna be fun to figure it out.
I think there's a fun Q&A
at the end of every day,
if we can sneak it in.
That video that I just made
that I put on Instagram Story
that we'll put in here,
like I'm challenging myself.
But in the comments here on "WeeklyVee,"
I think one of the things that we can do
with this first episode,
"WeeklyVee" number one,
'cause we're in it right
now, in the comments,
'cause we will read all of
them, what do you feel like
you intuitively feel that I could bring
to the table, you hear
about in other places,
my podcast, my content,
that you'd love to see
in a weekly show?
Punchline, please leave a ton of content,
comments and content, in the
comments section right now
of things that you would
like to see from "WeeklyVee,"
things that you feel
like you've been missing,
things that you'd like to
see more of, let us know.
(energetic hip-hop music)
Yeah, I don't even think
about year one, two, or 20.
To be honest, I think about,
I think about the fact that Leon Hess
bought a minority share
of the New York Jets
for what was absolutely nothing,
and that Super Bowl I did not sell out.
I think about NBA franchises
on the cusp of bankruptcy
in the early '80s, and the NBA
Finals being on tape delay,
and now there are
multibillion-dollar franchises.
So, for me, I know for a fact that esports
is going to be a substantial part
of the culture in 20 years.
I have enormous hopes and aspirations
that the Call of Duty League
is at the top of that,
and if that's the case, the
return on the investment
will be significant and meaningful,
and I'm looking forward to that.
But this, to me, is a
20-year, 30-year ROI play.
All right, I have to run
on stage, love you guys.
Thank you so much for the opportunity.
Bye-bye, bye, everyone,
thanks, Maha, bye-bye.
That was a real line right there.
That's how I live my fuckin' life,
whether it's Call of
Duty, whether it's me,
myself, GaryVee, whether it's
launching an Internet site in 1996
when everybody shit on me.
Guys, nothing I'll do
in my life is gonna be
more shit on than when I
launched WineLibrary.com.
You're fuckin' young, and
for the older dogs in here,
like me, you know exactly
what I'm talking about.
In 1996, the whole Internet was a fad.
So it wasn't even a bad idea
within something accepted,
it was a bad idea in
something not accepted.
It's literally, for
the youngsters in here,
it's literally like saying
that I'm gonna start a restaurant on Mars.
People are like, "Cool,
have fun with that."
So, yeah.
Just did a interview with Business Insider
for the Minnesota Rokkr,
put up the logo right here.
Fresh logo, right?
I'm a significant minority owner,
that's me telling you I don't own 1%,
and we have an opening weekend kickoff,
the Call of Duty League is
kicking off here in late January.
I'm super fired up.
I'll be in Minnesota all weekend.
Put up the dates here.
I hope I see you, come out, boom, boom.
Links in here, "WeeklyVee."
And so, oh, so we're gonna
come out Fridays after,
"WeeklyVee," I gotta keep that in mind.
So if there's things happening
Monday through Thursday,
I need to be smart.
But this one's not, it's
the following weekend,
so we're fresh.
Business Insider article, so
I just did that interview,
and now I'm going to speak
to the global leadership team
for ABI InBev, Budweiser,
all those big brands
in a small offsite here at CES,
because they bring in all their people
from around the world, and
then a bunch of meetings,
and then to the airport,
and then back to New York.
I'll try and do some selfie videos,
'cause DRock will make me,
to fill up "WeeklyVee,"
and then Friday, tomorrow, in the office.
(uplifting music)
- [Caleb] Which is a
trending song on TikTok.
You know what I'm talking
about with 52-card pickup
- Yeah, what do I do with that?
I forget how 52-card pickup--
- You have like to just like,
(mimics cards shuffling)
So basically, right after we film this,
you could turn to Jason's camera
here and intro "WeeklyVee."
- That's smart.
- With, like, a quick,
"And welcome to 'WeeklyVee'
"episode 001, 'WeeklyVee,' motherfucker."
Or like--
- Just get pumped.
- [Jason] Yeah, like,
just make good content,
like, I got shit to do,
but like I'm, you know?
- I don't know what you're doing, but...
(Caleb and Jason laugh)
But I think I do.
- I think--
- You need a, let me rephrase.
- [Jason] I want a dynamic
intro to each weekly vlog.
I think we're doing
this behind the scenes--
- I think we just made it.
This is "WeeklyVee" 001.
- Motherfucker!
(all laugh)
- Motherfucker.
- [Jason] Let's just do it just in case.
- Respect.
- Whenever you're ready.
- So, what is it again?
- I would just start off
with something like--
- Magician, magic trick, 52-card pickup.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then show this?
- Yeah, if it works out that way,
- I got it.
TikTok, as you guys
know, I'm no Zach King,
I don't do magic tricks, but...
(cards shuffling)
52-card pickup, oh, I got it!
You're gonna fuckin' die.
- [Caleb] Boom.
Wow, that's actually better than you--
- And this is "WeeklyVee"
001, motherfucker!
"WeeklyVee," just to go triple meta,
we just came in here, made a TikTok,
tried to get an intro for "WeeklyVee."
DRock was super wrong about a
meeting I'm about to go into.
It's been a day.
- Time out!
(bright music)
- I'm calling Charlie.
Charlie, hey!
Listen, I have a favor.
Can you do me a favor and never
talk to Ryan Harwood again?
(crew members laugh)
No, I know, but I'm
actually being serious.
(crew members laugh)
Don't ever speak to him again, okay?
When he calls, text him back
and just say, "Who dis?"
"Who dis?", got it?
All right, have a great day!
Keep up all the great work, proud of you.
Tell me when.
- Go ahead.
- Told you.
- [DRock] Keep going.
- Yep!
Five more seconds.
- Told you!
(playful music)
- Oh, morning!
- People have no relationship with time.
Everything feels like just yesterday,
and everything feels likes 64 years ago.
Feels like we've worked together forever.
- I know.
- How long has it been?
- Nine months.
- Really feels like we've worked
a long time together, DRock.
- [DRock] It's only been five years.
- Five years too long, right?
(Gary and DRock laugh)
And it was in 2010, it
is right now in 2020,
and I can't wait to have no fuckin' hair
in 2030 and make this
fuckin' trifecta video
for you on whatever fuckin' new platform
called JingJong there
is in the fuckin' world.
(playful music)